If you want to hear my ideas about the meaning
of Midsommar, stick around to the end of this
video.
Welcome back to Things You Missed.
I'm not going to attempt to fully explain
every little image in this movie, because
there's so much packed into it, and I'm not
familiar with the culture that it's based
on.
So in this video I'm just going to tell you
what I did notice, what connections I made
and my interpretations are.
So the movie starts with this painting of
the village divided up into four sections,
Spring, Summer, Fall and Winter.
This image establishes the cyclical themes
that we'll see in the movie: the cycle of
seasons throughout one year, the cycle of
life, death, impregnation and rebirth and
the actual class system that the commune uses.
The Swedish-American friend Pelle explains
that children under 18 are considered to be
in Spring section of their lives Spring is
known for leaves starting to grow on the trees,
so it goes along with the idea of their children
growing up, maybe even hitting puberty and
growing hair.
Ages 18 to 36 are considered Summer, when
the trees are at their fullest.
Our characters fall in this age range, and
they in their prime during this movie.
The events take place on Dani's birthday drawing
attention to the fact that we are supposed
to notice that they're in their prime.
There's even talk at the beginning that the
boyfriend Christian could be wasting his time
with Dani, they tell him he could be with
that waitress right now.
And of course, the movie takes place in summer.
I'm sure you didn't miss the title of the
movie: Midsommar.
Ages 36-54 are Autumn, and this is when the
leaves start to fall off the trees and they
start to decline.
This could be seen as when adults start losing
hair and reaching the end of their reproductive
fertility.
Ages 54-72 are Winter, which maybe explains
why the cultists were so upset when Christian's
friend Mark pees on the dead tree, because
they see it as a symbol for their own passed
elders.
When Dani asks what happens after 72, he gives
her a cut-throat gesture.
I think we see this happen in the ceremony
on the second day they are there, where two
of the oldest looking villagers, referred
to as "the ones", lead the feast, and then
sacrifice some blood on the runes at the top
of the cliff.
The American characters are shocked by the
diving scene that follows.
Another cycle we see in the movie is the day
night cycle.
Dani has a painting in her living room of
two moons in the night sky.
It provides a contrast to their destination
in Sweden, where the days last twice as long
as the nights.
When they enter the village they come through
this big sun shaped structure, and the platform
in the center of the village has a sun painted
on it.
The city they come from seems to be in the
middle of Winter, so they go from Winter with
two moons, to summer with two suns.
Also, when Christian is eventually garbed
in the cult's traditional clothing towards
the end of the movie, a sun and moon can be
seen on his robes.
There are more symbols about the circle of
life, like when they first arrive and there
is an older woman chanting prayers in what
I'm assuming is Swedish.
There are not always subtitles showing during
these prayers, but this time there are, she
says "spirits back to the dead".
Whenever Dani drinks that tea that gives her
the drug trip, she sees grass growing on her
feet, an image commonly associated with the
idea that the dead are taken back by nature.
When the tourists get freaked out by the cliff
jumping scene, one of the village elders tries
to calm the girl down by explaining that life
is a circle, and it's actually a great joy
for them to die and give their spirits to
the upcoming newborns -- and I know I'm not
supposed to put my opinion but that guy who
drove his leg didn't look too joyful.
I could be wrong but in my culture, screaming
in fucking agony is not typically a sign of
joy.
When Dani and Christian talk about it afterwards,
he says that it was shocking, but his tone
of voice says otherwise.
He suggests that they keep an open mind and
try to acclimate to the culture.
From this point on in the movie they transition
from spectators of the ritual to participants,
becoming a part of the ritual, taking on the
traditional clothing, and eventually Dani
is even able to speak their language during
the dancing competition.
As they become apart of the cult, they become
a part of the cycle, and one of the women,
Maya takes an interest in Christian.
Dani later becomes the May Queen.
Maya, May, they could both be a reference
to the calendar month of May, where Spring
starts to become Summer.
Pelle explains that Maya was recently approved
for some ritual, it basically means she's
allowed to reproduce, because she too is going
from Spring to Summer and becoming an adult.
Pregnancy is focused on throughout the movie.
In the very beginning, the Christian and his
friends are out at the restaurant, one of
the friends sees their waitress walk away
and says, "you could be getting that girl
pregnant right now."
Kind of a weird thing to say if not for the
circle of life metaphor.
Also, the way they are seated at the table.
They are seated in an arc similar to the way
the women are standing around Christian and
Maya during the impregnation ritual.
There's also a picture frames above the table
of a woman bending over.
The shot is composed so that only her breasts
are in frame, another parallel to the ritual.
That's the most literal reference to the rebirth
metaphor, there are also more symbolic ones,
such as all the women in the commune dancing
in a circle around this phallic structure.
During the feast after the big dancing competition,
an overhead shot shows a food sculpture in
the middle of the table representing an unclothed
woman and I'm the next shot, the phallic structure
is lined up over the body of this woman.
There are some images from the beginning of
the movie before they go to Sweden that come
back later in the movie.
Above Dani's bed at her apartment there's
a picture of a bear kissing a girl.
Dani's boyfriend ends up inside of a hollowed
out bear for the final ritual of the movie.
In that room Christian is taken to so the
older lady can ask him to impregnate Maya,
there is an image of a bear on fire on the
wall, another foreshadowing of his fate.
In Christian's friend's apartment, there is
a similar foreshadowing.
He has a framed picture of the scarecrow from
The Wizard of Oz.
In that final burning ritual, there are people
whose corpses are stuffed with hay like a
human scarecrow.
Also, during that scene in the apartment,
after Dani shows up everyone kind of bails
out besides her and Pelle.
He seems genuinely interested in her I think
he already knows she's fit to be the May Queen
and join his family.
He tells her “I am so happy you are coming”.
Then when the whole group arrives, the village
elder says, "We are so happy to have you,"
only making eye contact with Dani as he says
so.
Then when Pelle and Dani have the one on one
talk, he again emphasizes his pleasure that
she came with.
He challenges the idea that she is really
happy dating Christian and tells her the story
of how his parents died and the family was
there for him.
Dani and Christian become more and more distant
during this time, which is visually conveyed
when he gives her the birthday cake with the
candle and literally can't keep the flame
between them burning.
Pelle explains that the family didn't bicker
over what's theirs and what's not.
We see this because the babies are raised
by the community, not just the parents.
When Dani looks through the keyhole and sees
her boyfriend cheating on her, a group of
several women cry and suffer with her in contrast
to her crying on her boyfriend's lap with
him not really reacting.
Christian and his friend Josh bicker over
who gets to write the thesis paper on this
community, but they recommend that the two
share the topic.
I think this conversation Pelle has with Dani
helps me understand the character arc that
Dani goes through in the movie and how the
cult helps her get there.
At the beginning she’s too emotionally dependant
on her boyfriend, and she’s afraid that
she leans on him too much, which is only worsened
by her family tragedy.
He is considering breaking up with her because
it’s too much for him.
Then, she is introduced to the family, and
she sees how they have this community to support
each other.
Pelle gives her thoughtful gifts, and she
becomes a part of the family after winning
the dance competition and becoming the May
Queen.
At the end of the movie, they ask her to pick
the next sacrifice and she essentially becomes
the one to break up with Christian and become
a permanent part of the family when she chooses
him.
Now as far as the actual rune characters seen
all over the village go, again, I don’t
know the culture and I don’t really have
a way of translating them, but here’s what
I was able to figure out throughout the film.
There are two characters that come up over
and over again.
First there’s this R shaped one, which is
sometimes seen rotated or flipped.
It’s on the birthday drawing that Dani receives,
at the top of the cliff where the jumping
ritual takes place, on Dani’s robes and
on the clothes Christian receives.
It can also be seen on the doors to the room
where the impregnation ritual takes place,
and I’m pretty sure it shows up in more
spots around the commune.
This is the only symbol in the village that
I know the meaning of, because one of the
of cult members points to it in the book of
rune characters and says it represents grief.
It’s obvious why it’s so often associated
with Dani.
The other one that appears a lot is this hourglass
shape.
It shows up in the weird comic strip looking
thing that they refer to as a love story for
some reason and on both characters’ outfits
and around the village.
Most of the meals that they eat are done so
a table that forms this shape when viewed
from overhead and the pattern that the fire
burns in the final ritual also resembles this
shape.
Let me know if the comments if you have ideas
on what it could mean.
Although this is only the second film by the
director, Ari Aster, there are a number of
director's trademarks that are already evident.
This part of the video will contain spoilers
for his first movie, Hereditary.
Family tragedy occurs in both movies, Midsommar
opens with the death of Dani's sister and
parents, and Hereditary shows the decapitation
of the daughter, Charlie.
Reincarnation is a theme in both movies.
In Midsommar it's implied that the spirits
of "the ones" are reincarnated into the Maya's
baby.
Hereditary is all about reincarnating this
demon named King Paimon.
Obviously both movies center around cults.
This next one almost seems to be not only
an Ari Aster trope, but also an A24 trope
and seems to be turning into a horror genre
trope lately as well.
I'm talking, of course, about using naked
people, and more specifically naked old people
for scares.
Not sure how this one got started, I think
it may have been It Follows.
So that’s what I noticed about Midsommar,
and I’m sure there’s more that I missed,
so if you caught anything, let me know in
the comments.
If you want to see the Things You Missed episode
I did on Hereditary then click the video on
the left and remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.